Gençler merhaba. Hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
9. sınıfın artık son konularına
başlıyoruz. Bir hafta içerisinde bütün
konularınız bitecek. Bugünkü dersimizde
vitaminleri ve ayraçları işleyeceğiz.
Özellikle vitaminlerin temel görevlerine
vurgu yapacağız. Anlaştık mı? O zaman ne
diyoruz? Hadi gelin birlikte öğrenelim.
Düzenleyici olarak görev yapıyorlar.
Hocam bunlar enzimlere yardımcı grup
yani kofaktör oluyorlardı. Hatırlayın
lütfen. Besinlerle almak durumundayız ve
bunlar sindirilmezler arkadaşlar. Tamam
mı? Doğrudan hücreye alınırlar. Doğrudan
kana alınırlar. Vücutta tabii çok az
miktarda oldukları için yapıya
katılmaları ya da enerji verici olarak
kullanılmaları beklenmez. Tamam.
Vitaminler enerji verir mi? Sorusunun
cevabı hayır.
Herhangi bir vitaminin eksikliğinde o
vitamine ihtiyaç duyan metabolik
faaliyeti gerçekleştiremezsiniz.
Dolayısıyla bir vitaminin eksikliği bir
başka vitaminle giderilemez arkadaşlar.
Anlaştık mı? Bu da mineraller gibi
benzer cümlelere sahip. Bazı vitaminler
özellikle burada biz A, D, EK gibi yağda
çözünen vitaminlerden bahsederiz.
Vücutta depolanır. Bazılarında fazlası
idrarla atılır. Bunu da genel anlamda B
ve C vitamini olduğunu söyleriz.
Özellikle C vitamini arkadaşlar fazlası
idrarla atılır. Yani bir kasa portakal
suyu da içsen, bir bardak portakal suyu
da içsen alacağın C vitamini vücudun
ihtiyacının üzerine çıkmıyor. Vücutta
depolanabilen bir vitaminin eksikliği
belirti olarak kendini geç gösterir.
Çünkü zaten depolamışsındır. Sen onu
belli bir süre almadığında da
depolarından alırsın. Ama C vitaminin
eksikliği hemen kendini gösterir. Çünkü
depolamamışsındır. Böyle cümlelere de
dikkat edin. Yağda çözünen vitaminler A,
D, E, suda çözünenler B ve C vitamini.
Arkadaşlar dediğim gibi temel mantığa
odaklanmanız lazım. Her şeyi moto
ezberleyemezsiniz, öğrenemezsiniz.
En spesifik görev ve özelliği bilmekte
fayda var. Mesela A vitamini dediğim
zaman bunun görme ile alakalı olduğunu
özellikle beta kararotenden sentezlenen
bir lipit olduğunu, betakaroten havucun
içerisinde bol miktarda bulunan yapı,
madde. Karaciğerde A vitaminini
arkadaşlar eğer siz öncül olarak
alırsanız çevirebiliyorsunuz. Böyle iki
tane vitaminimiz var. Öncüllerini alıp
kendisinin olgun formuna
çevirebildiğimiz işte A ve D vitamini. D
vitamini de birazdan söyleyeceğim deri,
karaciğer ve böbrek üçlüsüyle aktif D
vitamini formuna geliyordu. Bakın A
vitamini görme ile ilişkili. Antioksidan
olarak da görev yapar. Eksiklik
belirtisi hemen ortaya çıkmaz. Neden? Az
önce söyledik. Dedik ki bunlar
depolanıyor. Eksikliğinde ama ne var?
Gece körlüğü denilen bir hastalık var.
Tabii bir şeyin eksikliği ile beraber
aşırısı da problem yaratabilir. Bakın
fazla miktarda alınması zehirlenmeye
neden olur. Ki şöyle bir genel kültür
tadında bilgi. Kutup ayılarının
karaciğerini yemek insanlar için ölümcül
olabilir. D vitamini kolesterolden
sentezlenen steroid yapılı. Peki hocam D
vitamini bir dizi tepkime sonucunda
insan vücudunda sentezlenebiliyormuş.
Evet sıfırdan değil. Öncülünü alıyorsun.
Deri, karaciğer ve böbrek üçlüsüyle
aktif D vitamini formuna çeviriyorsun.
Fazlası karaciğerde depolanıyor. A, D,
EK, adekten aklımızda kalsın. D
vitaminini gördüğünüz anda özellikle
arkadaşlar kalsiyum ve bir miktar da
fosforun emilmesinde görevli olduğunu
bileceksiniz. O yüzden bir insan D
vitamini almazsa otomatik olarak
kalsiyum eksikliği yaşar. Kalsiyumda
kemiklerin gelişimi için önemli olduğu
için siz bir çocukta D vitamin eksikliği
yaratırsanız raşitizm, yetişkinde ise
osteomalazi
özellikle kemik yumuşaması görülür
arkadaşlar. O yüzden D vitamini
kalsiyumla ilişkili ifadesini
unutmayacaksınız. Bakın D vitamini
eksikliğinde çocuklarda gerçekten
ortopedi kısmında daha doğrusu bunu
pediyatride yapacaksınız ama çekimler
yaptığınızda bu şekilde böyle içeri
doğru o bacak göreceksiniz arkadaşlar. E
vitamini yine bir antioksidan.
Antioksidan ne demek hocam? Aslında
serbest radikal oluşumunu engelliyor. Bu
birazcık böyle kimya gibi görünse de ben
size şöyle bir örnek vereyim. Siz bir
molekülden arkadaşlar elektron
kopartırsanız onda bir elektron açığı
yaratırsınız. İşte bu elektron açığı
olan madde elektron açığını kapatmaya
çalışır. Bizim vücudumuzda elektron
açığı nasıl kapatılır? Hücre zarından.
Hücre zarında fosfolipit katmanlar var
ya onlar negatif yüklü. Elektron bol
orada gider. Bu madde hücre zarına
saldırır. Hücre zarına saldırırsanız
hücrenin bütünlüğü bozulur. Bütünlüğü
bozulursa da problem olur. İşte bu
antioksidan kelimesi şuradan geliyor.
Bak diyor. Sen o maddenin yani elektron
açığı olan maddenin elektron açığını
kapatırsan
bir yere saldırmaz.
Saldırmazsa hücre bütünlüğü bozulmaz.
Hücre bütünlüğü bozulmazsa da ben
yaşlanmam. Yani yaşlanmam derken
yaşlanmam yavaşlar. İşte arkadaşlar, E
vitamini gibi bir madde
olası saldırı pozisyonunda olan bir
molekülün elektron açığını kapatır.
Antioksidan mantığı budur. E vitamini
özellikle üreme organlarının
işlevlerinin normal gerçekleştirilmesi
için gereklidir. İşte duyarsınız işte E
vitamini eksikliğinde kısırlık meydana
gelir gibi cümleler kurarlar. Ama
aslında bu arkadaşımızın en önemli
görevi antioksidan olması.
K vitamini kanın normal pığtlaşma
süreçleri için önemlidir. K vitamini
eksikliğinde pıhtlaşma bozuklukları
meydana gelir. Özellikle arkadaşlar K
vitamini bağırsaklarımızdaki
mikroorganizmalar tarafından da
üretilir. Fakat yine mesela ileride işte
pediyatri hekimi olursanız bir bebek
doğduğu anda arkadaşlar daha
doğumhanedeyken siz gideceksiniz bebeği
alacaksınız. Anneyle kadın doğumcu
ilgilenirken siz bebekle
ilgileneceksiniz ve bebeğe bazı aşılar
yapacaksınız. Bunlardan bir tanesi işte
K vitamindir. Neden? Çünkü bebeğin daha
bağırsak florası yani bağırsağın
içerisindeki bakteriler henüz
olgunlaşmadığı için bebekte K vitamini
eksikliği olabilir. Olsun hocam. Ne
olacak? Olmasın. Çünkü küçük küçük
beyinde minimal kanamalar oluşabilir
arkadaşlar. Bu da bebek için ciddi
riskler oluşturabilir. B grubu
vitaminleri ayırmayın diyor müfredat.
Yani gidip de B1, B2 falan diye
öğrenmeyeceğiz. Genel anlamda
öğreneceğiz. Yine B vitamininin birçok
formu bağırsaklarımızdaki
mikroorganizmalar tarafından
üretilebiliyor. Yani K ve B şeklinde
kalın bağırsak olarak kafanızda
kodlarsanız arkadaşlar K ve B'nin insan
vücudunda üretildiğini
en azından aklınızda tutarsınız. Bakın
biz değil mikroorganizmalar üretiyor. B
grubu vitaminlerin çoğu vücutta
depolanmaz. Fazlası idrarla
uzaklaştırılır. O yüzden düzenli bir
şekilde B vitamini almamız gerekir.
Eksikliğinde çok fazla B vitamini türevi
olduğu için çok fazla hastalık var
aslında. İşte hangi B vitamini mesela
unutkanlığa mı neden olacak, anemiye mi
neden olacak? Sinirsel birtım
problemlere mi neden olacak? Deri
hastalıklarına mı neden olacak? Bir sürü
B vitamini olduğu için hangisi eksikse
onunla ilgili sıkıntı meydana gelir.
Gelelim C vitaminine. Bu da eğer yani
her şeyi unuttum hocam ben dedin
diyelim. C vitamini alakalı neyi
kesinlikle unutmaman lazım? Bağ dokuda
kolajen denilen protein sentezinde görev
alır. Ve arkadaşlar bakın C vitamini
eksikliğinde
insanlarda şöyle bir hastalık
oluşuyormuş. Skörbüt. Şimdi skörbüt bu
bir denizci hastalığıymış. Yani
denizciler denize çıktıkları zaman böyle
aylarca karaya gelmiyorlar ve denizde de
C vitamini alabilecekleri bir şey
olmadığı için çok ciddi C vitaminiin
sıkıntısı çekiyorlarmış, eksikliği
çekiyorlarmış. Ve bağ doku kolajen
proteinleri sentezlenmezse dokuların
bütünlüğü bozulur arkadaşlar. Mesela
diyelim ki damarınızın bütünlüğü
bozuldu. O zaman ne olur? Damarınız o
bütünlüğünü kaybettiği zaman aralardan
kan sızdırmaya başlar. İşte bu kişilerde
C vitamini eksikliğine bağlı olarak iç
kanamalar meydana geliyor. Yani sadece
işte diş etiyle falan alakalı problemler
değil. İç kanama. Tabii bunu bir ada
doktoru fark ediyor. Tedavi ne? Bir
bardak portakal suyu. Yani işin esprisi
bir kenara C vitamini eksiğini yerine
koyacaksınız ve bağ dokunun o
proteinleri sentezlemesini
sağlayacaksınız.
Ama bir genel kültür daha vereyim size.
Bağırsaklardan demir alımını arttırır.
Şimdi sizin arkadaşlar mesela diyelim ki
kahvaltıda ya da işte herhangi bir
sebzede demir almak istiyorsunuz.
Diyorsunuz ki işte hocam bu sebzenin
demiri çok yüksek ama bitkilerdeki demir
+3. Değerlikli arkadaşlarım,
şimdi biraz böyle Barış hocanız
hekimliği bir de genel kültürü size en
azından şöyle bir heyecanınızı arttırmak
için versin. Şimdi demir +3 değerlikle
bizim ise bağırsaklarımızdan demiri
alabilmemiz için demirin +2 değerli
indirgenmesi gerekiyor. Çünkü bizde
divalent metal transporter denilen
divalen iki değerlikli metal transport
eden kanallar var. Yani ince
bağırsağımız diyor ki kardeşim sen +3
yüklü verirsen bana ben bunu hani
verimli bir şekilde vücuda alamam. Bana
2 değerlik ver bari diyor. Ama sen de
diyorsun ki kardeşim aldığım besinin
içerisine +3 ver. Şimdi öyle mükemmel
bir mekanizmaya sahibiz ki bizim
midemizde zaten asit var. Ne var?
Hidroklorik asit.
Demir + 3'ü asitle demir + 2'ye
indirgiyoruz. Ama bazı insanların
midesinde problemler oluyor. İşte asit
engelleyici kullanıyor vesaire. Hocam
bak o salatanın üstüne limon sıkıyoruz
ya
da nar eksi döküyoruz ya özellikle limon
asit işte o asit o sebzedeki demir + 3'ü
demir + 2'ye indirger faydalı hale
getirir. Tabii burada o limonu ilk
sıkanın limonu sıkma nedenini
bilmiyoruz. Tadı güzel diye mi iç
güdüsel mi? Ama neymiş olayımız?
Bitkilerdeki demir +3. Demir + 2'ye
indirgemek çok kıymetli. Çünkü demir + 2
halinde vücuda demir iyonu alınıyor.
Bakın bağırsaklardan demir alımını
arttırır ifadesini de ezberden böyle
genel kültüre evirmiş olduk. Son başlık
burada organik moleküllerin
belirlenmesinde kullanılan ayraç. Şimdi
ayraç dediğin şey bir kimyasal madde ve
sen bu kimyasal maddeyi ortama
koyduğunda herhangi bir renk değişikliği
olunca sen diyorsun ki aa bu madde var
ya da yok.
Ben diyorum ki ayraçların temel görevi
mesela sınavda soru olabilir. Mesela
organik bileşiklerin kimyasal yapılarını
ve saflıklarını belirlemek için
kullanılabilir.
Kirleticileri tespit etmek için
kullanabilir. Çünkü bir şeyi
ayırıyorsun. Bak ayıraç ortamda var mı
yok mu anlamaya çalışıyorsun.
Bir maddenin ortamda var mı yok mu
analizlerinde ya da eğitim amaçlı
deneylerde ayraçlar kullanılır. Bizim
özellikle çok fazla kullandığımız
nişasta ve glikojen gibi
polisakkaritlerin ayracı iyottur. İyot
nişastayla tepkimeye girdiğinde mavi mor
tonları ki bazen siyaha çalan bir ton
olduğu için bazen mavi siyah da deniyor.
Mavi mor tonları oluşur. Glikojende ise
kahverengi oluşur arkadaşlar. E şimdi
ben bunları hani tabii ki milyon kere
anlattığım için ve hekimlikten önce de
moleküler biyoloji ve biyokimya
laboratuvarını çok kullandığım için
artık bunlar refleks. Bu arada
histolojide de bu ayraçları bilmeniz
lazım arkadaşlar. İleride tıp
fakültesinde mesela Benedikt çözeltisi
glikozun varlığını tayin eden bir
çözeltidir. Ama biz burada daha çok
arkadaşlar şeker odaklı konuşmuşuz. Yani
şeker demiş böyle spesifik bir şey
söylememişiz. Hani bir polisakkarit mi,
monosakkarit mi falan. Ortamda kiremit
kırmızısı bir renk oluşur. Protein
tayini yine çok kıymetlidir, çok
önemlidir hekimlikte de arkadaşlar. Hem
idrarda hem özel sıvılarda protein
tayini yapacaksınız. Yine arkadaşlar ne
var bakın.
Mor renk oluşması besin içeriğinde
peptit bağı içeren moleküllerin yani
mesela proteinlerin olduğunu gösteriyor.
Mesela kim bu? Sodyum hidroksit ve bakır
sülfat gibi arkadaşlar maddeler
eklendiğini. Ya burada sizin bilmeniz
gereken spesifik şey aslında neymiş? Biz
ayracı niye kullanıyoruz ve temelde
ayraçları işte hangi maddeler için
kullanıyoruz? Bunu bilseniz yeter. Yağ
tayini önce gidiyorsunuz o besini
alkolde çözüyorsunuz, filtre
ediyorsunuz. İşte süzüntüyü suya
döküyorsunuz. Eğer süzüntü bulanırsa
besinin içerisinde yağ varmış şeklinde
bir yorum yapıyorsunuz. Bu da yağ
tayini. Bakın Benedikt redükleyici
şeker. İşte fehlink yine redükleyici
şeker yani indirgeyici şekerler. Bir
üret protein, iyot, nişasta, sudan 3
lipitlerin, ninh hidrin reaktifi,
aminoasitlerin gibi. Burada hangi
maddenin ne işe yaradığı arkadaşlar eğer
sınav sorusu olacaksa öğretmeniniz ben
bunu sınavda sorarım demişse burada
böyle çok daha hani şey yok. Size
öğretebileceğim bir teknik, taktik yok.
Göre göre, okuya okuya arkadaşlar
bunlara alışıyorsunuz. Şimdi
etkinliklere girmeyelim. Burada bir mola
verelim. 10 dakika mola verin.
Sonrasında arkadaşlar etkinlikleri
izlersiniz.